Rick where'd you get a grenade I don't
know so there you are minding your own
business when suddenly something glanced
at your feet before you can even say
kaboom you realize that the mysterious
little object is live in aid what can
you do to survive a grenade blast a
grenade by itself isn't really anything
to be afraid of that is until the pin is
pulled you know that waffle pattern
outside most grenades
well imagine those as tiny missiles and
when the grenade explodes they spread
shrapnel in all directions these flying
metal fragments could seriously ruin
your day by injuring you or even killing
you so if one of these little bundles of
death lands at your feet what the heck
do you do
hit the deck or say a little prayer well
we are ready to blow this question wide
open here are our best tips to help you
survive a grenade blast number one move
when a grenade lands near you you'll
want to move faster than you've ever
moved before you've only got about one
second to run or jump away as fast as
you can in a best-case scenario you'll
get about four and a half meters
away from the blast that's about the
farthest most people can go in one
second number two hit the deck next get
as low to the ground as possible you'll
want to lie down on your stomach that's
the best way to avoid being hit by
shrapnel as it reduces the surface area
of your body that the shrapnel could hit
number three feet out so you're on your
stomach next to a grenade that's not
exactly how you thought your day was
going to go right well what you want to
do is position yourself with your feet
pointing towards the grenade that way if
the shrapnel does hit you it will enter
the soles of your shoes and maybe your
feet I know that's not ideal but it's a
heck of a lot better than having
treadmill hit your head
number four cover up whatever you do
stay down turn your face away from the
blast and cover your head eyes and ears
you do not want to expose your flesh let
alone your brain to any part of the
explosion the grenade explodes and now
the dust starts to settle through a
combination of your training and some
sort of miracle you're alive
congratulations you just survived a
grenade blast talk about having some
bragging rights grenades are extremely
dangerous weapons and they're not
something to be taken lightly if you
ever have the misfortune of going
toe-to-toe with one you want to put some
major distance between you and violent
death our advice is stay clear of them
if you can but what if you're not fast
enough
and this is it what if the grenade kills
me
well now you're dead you're really not
having a good day are you so what are
you supposed to do next well we took a
peek into the great beyond on our other
show called what if and now we're here
to help you survive whatever awaits you